Victor just showed us how he uses
a screen reader to access content.
Now, it's your turn to try
out using a screen reader.
This is chrome Vox lite.
A minimal but functioning screen reader,
written in JavaScript,
that we've injected into this page.
>> Click a button.
Heading one.
>> You can use the control panel at
the bottom of the screen to control
the screen reader.
>> This screen reader has very
minimal functionality, but
we can explore the page using
the previous and next buttons.
And click things,
using the click button.Give this a try.
Using Chrome Vox lite, navigate to the I
love accessibility button and click it.
A word is going to appear on the screen,
come back here and
enter it into the text box.